let's start today with the most exciting
titillating and electrifying topic for
my audience tax policy of course many of
you sent me a clip that we're going to
look at of Senator Bernie Sanders from
Vermont being interviewed by now CNN's
Chris Wallace formerly of Fox News in
this clip Bernie Sanders effectively
says confiscate all income above
999 million dollars per year how many
people in the United States does this
even apply to it's very few I'll tell
you roughly the number in a moment but
what we're talking about here is a 100
percent
effective tax rate on income at a
billion dollars a year or more but don't
take my word for it here's Bernie
explaining it himself sir you're saying
sir billionaire should not exist so are
you basically saying that once you get
to 999 million dollars that the
government should confiscate all the
rest I'm saying that we should go back
to a very progressive tax policy like
what we had under Dwight D ISO which
would mean that that over a billion
dollars basically it all goes to the
government you may disagree with me
fine yeah I think people can make it on
900 you know 99 million dollars now
there is some
it's not even debate it's sort of a lack
of clarity is Bernie talking about a 100
marginal tax rate on all income at a
billion or more per year or is Bernie
talking about a wealth tax
such that you are always brought back
down to a net worth of a billion dollars
it's not completely clear but because he
says the times of Dwight D Eisenhower
tax policy under Eisenhower was a very
very high marginal tax rate on income so
for the sake of today's discussion let's
assume Bernie is talking about income
taxes rather than a wealth tax so the
first question is has this ever been
done before the answer is no there is no
historical precedent for a 100 percent
marginal tax rate essentially
confiscating all income above a certain
threshold there are governments that
have put in place very high tax rates on
the wealthy at high levels that
effectively is close to a 100 percent
tax at an extremely high level but we
never had 100 percent
now just because you haven't done
something doesn't mean it's a bad idea
it's just that it hasn't been done so we
don't have something to to look to but
that's what really we're talking about
here for the sake of argument a 100
tax bracket that starts at a billion
dollars on your first 10 I forget
exactly where the tax brackets are right
now but on your first 10 grand everybody
pays zero federally of course and then
on that next bit you take pay ten
percent fifteen percent you get all the
way up to 35 37 percent
um at about half a million bucks and
then at a billion dollars it's a 100
tax rate the highest it ever got in the
US as Bernie mentions is under
Eisenhower in the mid uh 20th century
with a roughly 90 marginal tax bracket
but again that's on income above a
certain threshold there are European
countries with very high tax rates on
the wealthy but it's not 100 percent now
what I want to talk we're not going to
have a 100 tax rate anytime soon so what
I think is more useful to talk about is
how can we achieve the goal that Bernie
is espousing and the goal here is
to actually collect more in taxes from
the very very very rich and as we know
there are complex season complexities
and difficulties to actually enforcing
this sort of thing for all of the
different reasons that we've talked
about and I will talk to you again now
the question of how many people this
applies to is an interesting one
um in 2022
the Forbes billionaire list said there
were 724 billionaires in the U.S I
believe now it's gone up a little bit to
like 735 billionaires in the U.S they
don't all earn a billion a year but some
of them do so we're talking about a
policy that would apply to a fraction of
the 700 something billionaires in the
United States now one of the first
issues as I know many of you know is
that many of these billionaires don't
actually earn income they receive
dividends and are subject to capital
gains so then it's well it's not just
about income over 999 billion it's other
forms of of proceeds as well that are
not actually subject to income tax rates
the point here is what are the
mechanisms through which we might
achieve a goal that is quite frankly
quite popular among the American people
when you serve the American people and
you say
should taxation be used
to collect more money from the very rich
in order to fund social programs It's
relatively uncontroversial most
Americans say yes you should now I do a
deep dive into this in my clip called
how to actually tax the rich there is no
one policy that would cover all
situations but some of the things that
could or should be looked at is okay
raise the top marginal income tax rate
that will cover
income the earned income but many of
these folks don't earn wages and they're
able to reduce actual taxation in a lot
of different ways including by receiving
income in other ways so then you could
look at well we could impose a wealth
tax the problem with the wealth tax
would be that these folks would move
assets to countries with no wealth tax
or invest in assets that are difficult
to Value like artwork or rare
Collectibles okay but again remember
it's like with gun violence no one
policy
would cover every situation but the idea
is to get some of the low-hanging fruit
you can close tax loopholes like the
carried interest loophole the counter to
that is you can move assets offshore you
can change business structure you can
Lobby for a different loophole you can
shift Investments to tax-exempt assets
like municipal bonds and it's not
realistic for most hedge funds certainly
but
um that's another possibility you can
better fund the IRS to do more audits
some of the people that we're talking
about are doing everything legally
incorrectly and paying every dollar that
they should be paying in taxes so audits
wouldn't recover any money from them but
there are some that um that that are not
and so uh increasing IRS resources is an
idea a financial transaction tax with
the ultra wealthy engaging in certain
types of transactions that average
income people do not engage in a
financial transaction tax is a
possibility of course the way to avoid
that would be
um weight just wait move assets to
countries that don't have such attacks
Etc you could require country by country
income reporting for companies one of
the ways that companies can avoid uh
corporate taxes now we're talking about
companies rather than individuals is
Shifting income to other countries that
is no longer subject to American
taxation you could pass a law that says
no that has to be reported and there has
to be some kind of corporate minimum tax
that is paid you can also look at
raising the tax rate on capital gains
and so that would get around this issue
of a lot of these very rich folks aren't
earning income
subject to income taxes so you can raise
the tax on capital gains the way around
that would be you just wait to realize
the gains or look at other mechanisms
and you can also expand the Alternative
Minimum Tax we already know that with a
minimum tax High earners can still
reduce their taxable income through
deductions tax credits and other
strategies but
um increasing that minimum tax is
another approach so those are ideas to
achieve what is the underlying principle
that Bernie is espousing here I don't
expect a hundred percent tax bracket
anytime soon in the United States I
never say never but certainly not in at
least the next five years there is new
polling that reveals the priorities of
Republican voters in 2024 and it is
utterly and fundamentally cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs the modern American
conservative movement is focus on some
really wild stuff CBS News poll on how
2024 Republican presidential primary
race could be Trump versus Trump fatigue
this is this is super interesting at
this early stage of the primary to the
the CBS News article reads to the extent
the Republican primary is a contest at
all right now it looks like it's one
between Trump and a sentiment one might
call Trump fatigue and Trump is winning
that matchup easily here's why Maga
sounding ideas are widely held in the
Republican electorate an environment
that plays javalee to Trump's Advantage
there's big demand for a candidate who
says Trump won in 2020 who challenges
woke ideas who doesn't criticize Trump
and for good measure makes liberals
angry Trump leads in all of those areas
meanwhile there are some Republicans who
say they're exhausted by Trump and he's
too controversial but they are greatly
outnumbered today check this out
uh top answers from likely Republican
primary voters these are folks who based
on their answers have been categorized
as likely to vote in the primary primary
remember that's a critically important
detail uh 2024 Republican nomination
can't uh likely Republican primary
voters prefer a candidate who 85 percent
challenges woke ideas
oh boy
opposes any gun restrictions
say Trump won the 2020 election
and 57
makes liberals angry now there are two
layers within which this is interesting
the first layer is Republicans for so
long have been insisting we care about
issues of importance to all Americans
economic issues jobs
inflation something like that we're
supposed to believe that's what they
care about when you look at the polls
the likely Republican primary voters
care about very different things the
most interesting part of this
is that
these interests
are likely to lead to a republican
candidate that is out of step with the
country as a whole let me explain what I
mean by that when Trump was arrested
and his approval went up among
Republican primary voters one of the
things we saw we surmised we noticed is
that while it is likely to help Trump in
the primary by energizing his base
because he's been treated so unfairly
you know the whole thing
um it's not likely to get him any new
votes in the general election and
similarly when we looked at Ron DeSantis
potentially running an anti-woke
campaign while that plays relatively
well with Republican primary voters when
you survey the country as a whole
wokeness for lack of a better term is
actually the more popular position and
similarly when you look at some of these
things if 85 percent of likely
Republican primary voters want a
candidate that challenges woke ideas but
roughly 57 to 60 percent of the country
sides with wokeness on trans issues and
on so many other issues you have a
scenario in which the person that
Republicans are most likely to select to
represent them in November of 2024 is
not actually the person most likely to
win that general election now this isn't
news to us when you look at polling that
does primary and then does hypothetical
general election match up you see Trump
does really well in the primary but
loses to Biden generally speaking on
average loses to Biden in the November
election so there's a few layers where
this is interesting one it confirms that
the not just Republicans in general
because you could be a republican who
plans to vote in November of 24 but
you're not engaged enough to vote in the
primary so this really is likely primary
voters the likely primary electorate of
the Republican Party
is very much out of step with the way
that the country as a whole is going
that's number one and then number two
we've said for a while now Republican
elected officials Republican candidates
better said have abandoned policy in
part because they're losing the country
on policy so instead they talk about
this sort of stuff let's do nothing on
guns let's fight wokeness let's ban
books Let's Stop drag shows whatever
else the case may be
that is in itself also not apparently a
winning ideology or a winning platform
they've lost on policy so they've
abandoned it and they've moved on to
cultural issues but they're also not
winning the cultural issues nationally
and yesterday we looked at how they're
losing on abortion and in other areas so
what are they to do
the answer is obvious it's what they've
been doing you try to win elections by
saying you won even if you lost and that
should really scare all of us because it
means they will almost certainly try it
again in 2024.
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
lest anyone forget or maybe you
misplaced our pamphlet on membership I
do want to remind you that our program
is primarily funded by our viewers by
our listeners through something called
the membership program you can sign up
at joinpakman.com we do an extra show
every single weekday for our members we
also offer commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show for you we make
the show available hours earlier every
day to our members and you can get a
discount I mean listen the prices are so
reasonable
um but if you'd like a 50 discount you
can use the coupon code indicted to save
off of the cost of a membership at
joinpakman.com something super
interesting is going on in the wake of
Fox News firing Tucker Carlson as Fox
struggles to find a suitable replacement
which we'll talk about more a little bit
later on in the show as Fox continues to
try to beat off other lawsuits current
and potentially future related to Tucker
Carlson's programming and what's going
on behind what went on behind the scenes
at his show we have additional leaks
that reveal Tucker's displeasure to put
it very light likely lightly with
elements of Fox News this is a Media
Matters report Fox leaks Tucker Carlson
slammed Fox Nation in behind the scenes
video this uh article is by former David
Pacman show guest Matt Gertz not Matt
Gates often confused this is by Matt
Gertz and
um it says Tucker Carlson headline Fox
news's Fox Nation streaming service in
the Years leading up to his sudden
firing but a behind the scenes video
obtained by Media Matters shows him
lashing out at Fox for the service's
unbelievable failings apparently while
doing some Imad image rehab for
misogynistic social media influencer
Andrew Tate now I have to tell you we're
going to look at the clip here of what
Tucker had to say about Fox Nation it's
a pretty damn accurate criticism of Fox
Nation Fox Nation is the streaming
little brother or sister of Fox News the
network channel and let's listen to what
Tucker had to say it's very very
interesting I don't want to be a slave
to Fox Nation which I don't think that
many people watch anyway
um we're gonna uh because I I you know
I'm like a representative of the
American Media now right speaking to an
exile in Romania and welcoming him back
into the Brotherhood of journalists
would help us out if you wore sweater
though because we asked him not to wear
a suit like he was panicking about it so
you don't have to Tucker's gonna be
looking casual okay so first of all this
is just endlessly funny apparently what
they're talking about is the you know
the guy Andrew Tate who was arrested for
a while and I don't even know what's
going on with him I don't follow Andrew
Tate Andrew Tate I guess normally wears
suits on interviews and it seems as
though they're trying to convince Tucker
for this foxination thing to wear a
sweater so that he is equally casual to
what they're expecting Andrew Tate to
wear I think that's what I'm
understanding here and Tucker's just
getting annoyed
is that okay
I mean this is airing on the nighttime
show and I want it to look official I
don't want it to be like bro talk and I
and I
you know what I mean
but nobody's gonna watch it on Fox
Nation nobody watches Fox Nation because
the site sucks
this is just the best that you know I
actually I I do not sympathize with
Tucker on almost anything but I've been
in situations where like you know I'll
have a direct affiliation with some
entity and then that entity has some
other affiliation and they end up making
requests for things they want me to do
like at a conference and I know that my
contacts are really just being bugged by
these other folks who I don't really
want to have anything to do with and
they make these requests and the the
frustration with Tucker about they're
trying to make me do stuff that's really
not good for me and it's not good for
anybody and nobody's gonna watch it
anyway
I really empathize with that
specifically beyond that you all know my
feelings about Tucker so I'd really like
to just put the dump the whole thing on
YouTube
um but anyway that's just my view
um
uh I'm just frustrated with uh in it's
hard to use that site I don't know why
they're not fixing it it's driving me
insane and they're like making like
Lifetime movies but they don't they
don't work on the infrastructure of the
site like what it's crazy and it drives
me crazy because it's like we're doing
all this extra work and no one can find
it it's unbelievable actually I don't
know who runs that site
[Music]
I know but we're doing our part we're
like working like animals to produce all
this content and the people in charge of
it whoever that guy's whatever his name
is like they're ignoring the fact that
the site doesn't work and it's I think
it's like a betrayal of our efforts
that's how I feel so I
I think I've had this exact phone call
with people like that this is the
funniest thing this it resonates so much
with me now of course what Tucker wants
to be disseminating instead of that is
absolutely horrible stuff the the real
story here is not Tucker's frustrations
per se
it's that it appears as though this
stuff was leaked from people associated
with Fox News directly to Media Matters
and it is such a stunning turn of events
when Fox people Fox Affiliated people
are leaking things to the to the
left-wing Media Matters and we're going
to see what ultimately happens with the
fourth com with the existing and
forthcoming lawsuits against Fox News
and the role that Tucker Carlson has to
play there I actually had I I just
filmed a podcast episode with Lex
Friedman very long episode like almost
four hours long pretty wide as well
probably three hours wide if you can
believe it and it's going to be released
soon and we talk about the claimed
reasons that fox fire Tucker which have
to do with politics which are false and
the real reasons that fox fire Tucker
which have everything to do with legal
liability and the fact that he's become
a real problem uh this to me is just
funny and Tucker's criticisms of Fox
Nation are absolutely spot on I've even
been invited on Fox Nation and they go
yeah listen we Fox producer here we'd
like to have you on oh like which show
well it's like the Fox Nation after the
show like the bonus show equivalent but
it's like not award-winning the way ours
is
um and also there's like a guest host
this week so and I'm sorry guys I'm just
too busy I'm just too busy I've got a
you know a baby running around diapers
everywhere it's crazy I can't do it I'm
sorry I can't do it so that I very much
identify with all right now let's move
to
how is the search for Tucker Carlson's
replacement going I told you yesterday
on the show that the Tucker Carlson hour
on Fox News lost about half of its
audience
um in the week after Tucker Carlson's
firing not hugely surprising people are
tuning in for Tucker right I mean when I
go on vacation we lose about 50 of our
audience as well
um the funny thing is that every guest
host that they seem to try over there
seems to just go worse and worse and
worse this one is really funny yesterday
the latest attempt at Tucker's
replacement is a guy named Lawrence
Jones who's worked at Fox News for some
period of time
he arguably did the worst job of anybody
so far he interviewed ASA Hutchinson ASA
Hutchinson is a republican candidate
he's a former Republican governor
Republican candidate for president for
the Republican nomination his campaign
is totally Dead on Arrival but they
interviewed him anyway fine the
interview lasted eight and a half
minutes the interviewer Lawrence Jones
spoke about half of that time more than
four of the eight and a half minutes
Lawrence Jones was speaking often
yelling over ASA Hutchinson and he tried
the wire you running sort of gotcha and
when ASA I mean listen I think the
policies are stupid and they're bad
policies but ASA Hutchinson is naming
the things he did as Governor which
Republicans generally do like and Jones
tries to short-circuit it by saying
every Republican does that stuff and
it's sort of like well what do you want
me to say I did the things Republicans
like listen to this humiliating attempt
at an interview
this is fair that that is spin
um the Republicans have said what their
position is I understand that you for
free speech and all these other issues
and like I said respectfully sir I
understand that you're for economic
freedom and all that those are the
typical Republican positions and that
would work back in 2008 or even 2006 but
there's a different Republican party now
and when I ask you the question why are
you running it seems like you're opposed
to all of the things that the modern day
Republican party stands for what do you
say to the
well I disagree with that I lowered
taxes in Arkansas that's real again
Republicans
you've got to listen to me as well
you've got to listen as well we've
balanced the budget that's what
Republicans do we lead in this country
yeah but did you make fun of a disabled
reporter do you pretend do do you
pretend weightlift to attack trans
people during your rallies that's what
the party wants now conservative
principles and whenever you're looking
at our values I stand second to none in
terms of fighting for pro-life values
and conservative values look at my
record Lawrence Governor I just went
through your record here and as I said
and I gave you credit for the normal
Republican positions you're writing live
but this is a new Republican party thank
you so much for your time sir
all right not exactly a conversation I
believe that the search continues for a
replacement for Tucker Carlson on Fox
News if you're curious you can check out
that that entire interview the good news
for Lawrence Jones is Almost no one is
watching fox in that time slot anymore
so not that many people saw him
humiliate himself it's hard to determine
who's less ready for prime time uh
Lawrence Jones or or Ron DeSantis and
what he did is he wanted to impress I
guess his bosses
so he came out ready to fight because
fight is good but when you just talk
over your guest and you speak for half
the interview when you're supposed to be
hearing the ideas of the other person it
just doesn't really work very well and I
expect we'll see what the numbers look
like by the end of this week I expect
that this week's Tucker ratings The
formerly Tucker ratings will be even
worse than last week so Fox News
certainly has some problems on its hands
I'm not too worried about helping them
solve those problems and if you're
curious what this interview looked like
we'll have the clip on our Instagram
which you can find by searching
Instagram for David Pacman show we're
going to take a quick break
so much more to discuss with you today
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's talk a little bit about the
shifting dynamics of the 2024 Republican
primary number of interesting things
happening over the last 48 hours first
and foremost failed former president
Donald Trump's very uh I would call it
an increasingly unhealthy obsession with
Florida Republican Governor Ron DeSantis
seems to be getting worse and worse and
worse Trump completely out of control
obsessed with Ron DeSantis posting
endlessly to truth social about him
sometimes MO multiple times per hour now
I pulled a bunch of trophs from a
24-hour period uh since then Trump has
continued posting so like I could give
you 10 more of these but I'm not going
to do that to you but just to give you a
sense of how obsessed Trump is with a
guy who as of right now isn't even
running against him and who by all
reasonable assessments can't even beat
Trump I mean Trump's already over 50
percent in most Republican primary polls
DeSantis is in the low 20s with a
campaign that seems to be slowing down
big donors abandoning DeSantis before he
even announces okay so it's like not
even really clear DeSantis is a major
threat to Trump regardless look at this
Trump going after DeSantis for coveted
death numbers by the way pretty unfair
because you really should go by rates
Trump just posting a chart of covet
deaths but it's like Florida has a huge
population so it would make more sense
to look at Cova death rates regardless
he says so explain why did Ron Des
Sanctus do a good job highly overrated
New York had fewer coveted cases now New
York is better than Florida for a while
Florida was better than New York no new
tricks just the per capita confusion
that we've always been seeing Trump
continuing Des sanctimonious had nothing
to do with Israel or the moving of the
U.S embassy to Jerusalem never so much
has mentioned it to me it was the last
thing on his mind to sank this wasn't
even Governor yet it was December of
2017 and I barely knew him he has turned
out to be a total flame out this is the
kind of disinformation I thought only
the Democrats would put out no wonder de
Sanctus is dropping like a rock in the
polls terrible
Trump continuing and remember this guy's
not running yet and he's also doing
terribly in the polls but Trump is just
obsessed collapsing at home DeSantis
travels to Israel and proclaims he moved
U.S embassy to Jerusalem not Trump but
it doesn't stop there again guys this is
like all within a few hours the
sanctimonious had a failed campaign when
he was running for governor he was ready
to drop out was way behind then I
capital E endorsed him it wasn't a
lowercase e endorsement it was a capital
E endorsement and he went big league but
artificially up the real de Sanctus
however is the guy we are all watching
crash a burn a really bad politician
enjoy the trip Ron Trump then retrothing
a guy named John Rich saying quote I
don't understand the logic of DeSantis
running let's just say he beat Trump in
the primary which won't happen but let's
hypothesize if he won there wouldn't be
one true Trump supporter left that would
vote for him and he would be destroyed
in a general election this is a losing
proposition no matter how you look at it
so why on Earth would he voluntarily run
head-on into the wood chipper now this
one is interesting for two different
reasons
Trump and failed Arizona gubernatorial
candidate Kerry Lake have both been
pushing this idea if DeSantis somehow
won the Primary
no Republicans would vote for him in the
general this is starting to be
an an odor of
maybe boycott the general if Trump
doesn't win the nomination which I
absolutely love the best scenario for
Democrats would be for Trump to lose the
primary and then for Republicans to
either stay home in protest or to write
Trump in or even better for Trump to run
third party and take 10 15 percent of
that vote those would be absolutely
dream scenario so that's an interesting
thing that Trump is now starting to
signal boost the idea of Republicans
wouldn't vote for DeSantis in the
general they wouldn't Kerry lake is
starting to signal boost that idea
that's number one number two that's
interesting about this is the idea of
really seeming to try to push DeSantis
not to even run it seemed at one point
that Trump was maybe looking forward to
the idea of a contested and heated
primary but now that Trump's talking
about I might not even debate
now that Trump's talking about maybe
DeSantis shouldn't even run it seems
that the tide has turned a little bit
and and the idea here is to prevent
DeSantis even from announcing okay Trump
continuing on Truth weirdly going after
Kaylee mcinanny his own former press
secretary saying quote I guess Kaylee is
no longer speaking so favorably about
Des sanctimonious now that his capital P
polls are shot and he said that after
Kaylee posted strong foreign policy
interview from Trump on Tucker Carlson
Trump excels when he talks policy yeah
right emphasizes his experience and
reminds Americans how safe our country
was on his watch this is just showing
you how sort of petty Trump is even
though this post from his former press
secretary is praising Trump I guess at
some point she praised santis and Trump
really didn't like that so he's still
going after her then Trump continuing
and I could keep going all day but this
will be the last one Trump posting I
couldn't care less if Ron Des Sanctus
runs but the problem problem is the
capital B Bill he is about to sign which
allows him to run without resigning from
being Governor totally weakens capital E
election capital I Integrity in Florida
instead of getting tough and doing what
the people want same-day voting voter ID
proof of citizenship paper ballots hand
count this bill guts everything so this
is endless this all these messages I
just showed you are all from a few hour
period Trump is obsessed with the Santos
it seems to be becoming an unhealthy
Obsession but the Strategic question
here of course is if DeSantis doesn't
announce
is it only going to get worse for him in
the sense that Trump is starting actual
campaign stuff he's doing events and he
even is going to do a town hall with CNN
let's talk about that next
so many of you emailing me this morning
the general message has been David sir
did you see that CNN is doing a trump
Town Hall have they not learned anything
from all of the free publicity they gave
him in 2016 is this because of Chris
Licht taking over CNN and number three
is CNN going to pretend that Trump's
just a normal candidate not a guy who
incited an insurrectionist Riot and has
been arrested are they really going to
pretend that he's a normal candidate all
absolutely great questions so let's dive
into it first and foremost here is Jim
shudo announcing on CNN that yes Donald
Trump will be doing a town hall next
week let's listen and just into CNN
former president Donald Trump will
participate in a CNN presidential Town
Hall next week the former president will
take questions from New Hampshire
Republicans and Undeclared voters who do
plan to vote in the 2024 GOP
Presidential primary CNN this morning
anchor Caitlin Collins will not rate the
May 10th Town Hall at Saint Anselm
College wow at 9pm Eastern time stay
with CNN news Central so I'm going to
give you both sides of this because I
have to say
this is a brilliant move uh uh
strategically by CNN
and it couldn't possibly come with
better timing so I'm going to explain
that in a moment
first let's talk about the kind of
societal implication and the problem
with this
um Trump is
unique in many senses and this election
is unique it's a former president who
lost re-election but is running again
but also tried to steal the election he
lost and has since been arrested and
indicted
and it's going to likely be a rematch
with the guy he lost to in 2020. totally
unique unprecedented situation in
American history so the problem with
just hey we're doing a town hall
is the normalization of trump as just
another candidate when he is arguably
one of the most dangerous departures uh
from uh how we expect the presidency and
democracy to work in the United States
our friend Brian Tyler Cohen found the
moment from Kara Swisher's interview
with CNN's current uh Chief Chris Licht
where he says we're not going to turn
into Trump 24 7. here he is saying it
this was uh just in November you ended
up talking about him for eight hours a
day and we're not going to do that we're
going to be very
um clear and take everything on a
case-by-case basis about what level of
coverage it should be so meaning that it
will not be quite hands we are not going
to be a 24 7 Trump News Network okay now
a lot of things have changed since
November 17th of 2022 when that podcast
episode was filmed and there are so many
absolutely accurate criticisms of what
CNN is doing our friend Aaron rupar
tweeted quote it shouldn't have to be
said but it's irresponsible for any
media Outlet to treat a guy who
attempted a coup after the last
presidential election like a normal
presidential candidate are they going to
treat him like a normal presidential
candidate next week on the town hall I
don't know so that is all
extraordinarily disturbing and
concerning we're going to have to see
how they treat him now let's get to the
genius of what CNN is doing and I I
again it's really important I'm not
praising CNN in terms of how they're
going to handle this I don't know how
they're going to handle it but I'm
extraordinarily concerned
The Genius of what CNN is doing is that
we now have and this was probably
planned before Tucker was fired by Fox
News we now have a situation where there
are certainly millions of people in the
United States at minimum
who are furious with Fox News they
wrongly believe Tucker Carlson's firing
was for political reasons they agree
with Trump's attacks on Fox News which
have been going on now for months you
have a group of people who are looking
for any reason to find something other
than Fox News to now become what they
watch
Trump going on CNN
is now giving all of those people the
opportunity to say you know what CNN
maybe is fake news or maybe it was back
when Trump was president but Fox Now is
a disaster I'm abandoning fox fox is now
the enemy and look CNN is at least
giving my guy the time of day they're
going to give him a town hall and
the timing is is actually quite perfect
for CNN from a business standpoint and I
am so curious to see whether
the attitude towards CNN changes
dramatically from Trump supporters I'll
tell you all it will take is Trump
during the town hall
praising CNN for having him and
attacking Fox and then after the fact
posting some truths about it
and others on the right saying hey you
know what we've been critical of CNN Fox
is the problem at least CNN is giving
you know my dad Don Jr can say at the
time of day or whatever else the case
may be and all of a sudden
it's not CNN becoming trumpian but it
totally changes the media picture now as
far as the substance
if CNN treats Trump the way he should be
treated I've talked about responsible
platforming so many times before
responsible platforming means you don't
rule someone in or out just on the basis
of who they are for an interview I've
interviewed white supremacists I've
interviewed homophobes I've interviewed
all these different things you've got to
platform them responsibly
and um if CNN were to do that and if
there is subject matter holding Trump to
account for the riotous Insurrection
that that he incited in terms of the
arrest all these things I am completely
fine with it do I expect that that's
what they're going to do it is not what
I expect that they're going to do and
who knows what may have been even
pre-negotiated with regard to some of
those things I will be watching with
great interest as a media analyst and
media critic but I'm going to withhold
judgment about whether CNN handles this
correctly or incorrectly until I see it
that'll be next week but that is the big
news Trump CNN town hall and this also
gets to
DeSantis by not announcing and remember
he can't announce unless he resigns in
Florida those are the rules from the
governorship unless he changes the law
which he's working on doing so he's got
a little bit of a problem he actually
can't announce right now if he wants to
remain Governor but the other problem
for DeSantis is as he's sort of
crumbling in the polls
he doesn't get any of these
opportunities unless he's actually a
candidate a maybe candidate is not going
to get a CNN Town Hall this is a growing
problem for Ron DeSantis that he's going
to have to figure out
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
the news that Noam Chomsky hung out with
the late Jeffrey Epstein has really sent
many people for quite a loop uh Chomsky
was asked about this and said none of
your business when the Wall Street
Journal inquired about it which is
striking at least some people in my
audience as a very strange response it's
the entire thing is not incredibly
newsworthy but I think what is setting
some people off is what they perceive to
be a really like the worst possible
response from gnome Chomsky now of
course Jeffrey Epstein
um who is now deceased
now understood to be an extraordinary
Predator involving uh young girls and
you know the the details are so beyond
the scope of what I can um uh sort of
illuminate here but this has been an
ongoing story for a very very long time
uh and he is an extraordinarily uh
horrifying predator and so every time it
turns out someone met with him this
happened to Bill Gates Trump and Clinton
knew Epstein it it always sort of
generates a little bit of a story but uh
Alan dershowitz is another one who
visited um Jeffrey Epstein's Private
Island I believe it was but Chomsky is
surprising some so there's a Business
Insider story renowned academic Noam
Chomsky told the Wall Street Journal
that his meetings with Jeffrey Epstein
are quote none of your business none of
your business The Wall Street Journal
reports that Chomsky held multiple
meetings with Jeffrey Epstein chomsky's
meetings with Epstein took place long
after the disgraced financier had
registered as a sex offender so the idea
of this was long before anybody knew
anything not valid it was it was known
when the journal asked Chomsky about the
meetings the linguist had some Choice
words and the article is it's a short
article let's look at it because it's
interestingly written when asked about
their connections with Jeffrey Epstein
many Business Leaders and bureaucrats
offer tight-lipped regrets and apologies
not Noam Chomsky The Wall Street Journal
in an exclusive published Sunday said it
obtained Epstein's private calendar it
outlined numerous meetings with
high-profile people including Chomsky
the famed academic and political
activist when the journal reached out to
Chomsky he had Choice words quote First
Response is that it is none of your
business or anyone's second is that I
knew him and we met occasionally Chomsky
94 told the journal in an email
Epstein the disgraced financier accused
of sex trafficking underage girls died
by suicide in 2019 in a Manhattan jail
as the awaited trial
um in addition to Chomsky the journal
noted meetings with a current CIA
director William Burns as well as
Catherine remler a top lawyer at Goldman
Sachs and former White House counsel
under Obama Epstein's meetings with
Chomsky appeared to have taken place in
2015 and 16. Epstein was first charged
with procuring minors for prostitution
and registered as a sex offender in
2008. in March of 2015 Epstein's
scheduled meetings was Chomsky and a
Harvard University Professor Chomsky
confirmed that there were several
meetings where they discussed various
topics the journal reported that months
later Epstein scheduled a flight with
Chomsky and his wife for a planned
dinner with movie director Woody Allen
and his wife Sun Yi Previn who is also
the adopted daughter of his ex-partner
Mia Farrow Chomsky said and this one is
a little weird if there was a flight
which I doubt it would have been from
Boston to New York 30 minutes see I
would remember whether I flew with
Jeffrey Epstein that I that's strange
but he says I'm unaware of the principle
that requires that I inform you about an
evening spent with a great artist
Chomsky said what was known about
Epstein was he had been convicted of a
crime and had served a sentence
according to U.S laws and Norms that
yields a clean slate so listen I agree
that the responses are a little bit odd
I also have no reason whatsoever to
believe that Chomsky did anything
inappropriate as it relates to the
things that Epstein was accused and
previously convicted of on the one hand
it would be really easy for Chomsky to
say listen Epstein contacted me to do
seminars for rich people because they
were interested in hearing my
perspective
um the the thing is if that's not true
why would Chomsky make that up and lie
if that's not actually what took place
and so I understand that Chomsky is
responding in what is sort of you know I
I you could say it's a strange response
but it also doesn't really suggest to me
that Chomsky did anything wrong
um I don't know that there's too much
more to say about it and quite frankly
it's not Ultra surprising to me listen
if you had said hey David you know
knowing that Epstein met with Clinton
Trump and dershowitz who else would you
guess he might have hung out with
my mind doesn't immediately go to
Chomsky but I do think it's important to
just kind of generally consider and
understand that
um it ends up being a small world in a
lot of ways and so when you say Chomsky
new Epstein it's not like a mind-blowing
shock to me at the same time if there's
any evidence at any point that comes
forward that Chomsky did anything wrong
we'll discuss it at this point there is
not radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green I
guess wants to ban the pornography site
PornHub
because of something related to Hunter
Biden this one's really difficult to
understand Daily Beast has a piece on it
Marjorie Taylor green wants to ban
PornHub because of Hunter Biden
Marjorie Taylor green is disgusted that
websites like PornHub exist and even
more horrified that Hunter Biden may
have used them
Raw Story reports that green shared her
Newfound knowledge of the adult film
landscape in a keynote address to the
Putnam County Ohio Lincoln Reagan dinner
let's listen to what she had to say
about PornHub and Hunter Biden this is
really weird United States doesn't want
to acknowledge this biological
grandchild won't even acknowledge it
and so Hunter Biden's hiding out in the
White House
here's what I found out this sweetie
there is a website you may or may not
have heard about it called PornHub
it is a disgusting porn website as a
matter of fact it should be illegal I
can't even I don't even know why it
exists
right they're against business
regulation
but ban the website
[Music]
and these are an accounts where he could
go watch pornography these are accounts
where he posted his sex videos oh like
the ones that are on the hunter Biden
laptop
this week I found out you want to know
what he still has an account on PornHub
whoa now I would also wonder does he
have Gmail and should Gmail be banned
does he have a New York Times
subscription should we ban the New York
Times this is so stupid but the crowd is
just enraptured by Marjorie Taylor green
telling the story where his videos are
posted
it is still live and active
this is the son of the president of the
United States
did someone just say fraudulent I gotta
I want to go back and hear that again
this is the son of the president of the
United States fraudulent yeah what's
fraudulent
disgusting vile embarrassment peace of
trash
and that is what is a reflection on our
country
geez then in that case how does Marjorie
Taylor green reflect on our country
that's scary stuff and they attacked
president Trump and his family
I don't care how people vote Republican
Democrat independent
non-political whatever
that fact right there should be so
offensive to every single American that
we do something about it
this political cycle has gotten so
stupid so so stupid so there's a couple
different things number one the idea
that a low regulation stay out of
business's way Etc Republican would want
a website banned made illegal
and of course when she says that it's
like should it be illegal to run the
website should it be illegal to visit
the website they're never really clear
you know the website should be illegal
because Hunter Biden has an account on
the website is some of the most specious
reasoning that I can imagine and again
to what other platforms I mean I don't
does Hunter Biden have a Twitter account
should Twitter be illegal because Hunter
Biden in theory could post videos to
twitter and he has an account there and
Twitter hasn't even closed it I don't
know the answer to that and it's again
another reminder they have their stated
principles
which matter not at all to them when
it's inconvenient and then all of a
sudden it's banned this ban that the
other thing the other thing I want to
mention is I continue to get emails
about why am I not talking about Hunter
Biden
what do you want me to say about Hunter
Biden the images that were not allowed
on Twitter around the time of the 2020
election
were
um images
sexually explicit images that were being
published without Hunter Biden's consent
that's illegal in Most states and
against Twitter's terms of service now
if you want to make the argument that
were those images not part of the
articles that were being posted the
article should have been allowed I'm
with you and in fact as I mentioned
earlier I just finished recording uh an
episode with Lex Friedman
for his podcast and the topic of Hunter
Biden came up and we talked about it a
little bit you know at this point it's
like do you still not have the evidence
to charge Hunter Biden for all of the
crimes he supposedly committed if he's
committed crimes go ahead and charge him
I don't know anyone on the left who
would say no he must be protected or
whatever else the case may be the fact
that it has been this long and Rudy
Giuliani had the hard drive Tucker had
the hard drive and got lost in the mail
and the blind computer guy had the hard
drive all these different things
and there's still no evidence of any
criminality of any substance maybe he
didn't really commit crimes I don't know
but I have no issue whatsoever with
Hunter Biden being investigated charge
prosecute whatever to the fullest extent
of the law but there's nothing else for
me to say about it at this point in time
given the fact that there doesn't seem
to be evidence that he committed any
crimes and certainly he has no
involvement in the Biden Administration
so that's where I am on the hunter Biden
stuff
we'll do a deeper conversation on it on
the Lex Friedman podcast because uh
because Lex brought it up all right so
that'll be released in the next few days
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here's a caller who at
least seems to think that he caught me
in a double standard let's listen this
is interesting
something else that I truly don't
understand all right
you are in favor of allowing women
to decide what to do with their body
true abortion
have a child
Etc right guilty perfect
sounds reasonable to me all right good
yet on the other hand
you criticize
perhaps make fun of people who want to
dictate how they want to treat their
particular illness or infectious disease
you can't have it both ways man explain
you can
I'm gonna exaggerate and say something
stupid but on purpose if I want to treat
covet or some other illness or
infectious disease with bleach
with cockroach
killer with uh
sawdust okay
you should let me do it
don't criticize it
there's two different things here
you should let me do it versus you
shouldn't criticize it and I'm sorry my
friend there is no double standard here
okay I have never advocated that it
should be illegal for an individual
who's confused right to go to the
hardware store
to buy Bleach or Drano
or whatever
and to apply it to the body interior
extra whatever
because they think that it'll treat
covet I have never said it should be
illegal I have never said when you go
and you grab bleach
they should ask you are you going to use
this for covet and if you say yes they
call the cops I have never said it
should be illegal what I have said is
it's stupid what I have said is there's
no medical science that says injecting
bleach is good for covet there is no
double standard I don't think abortion
should be against the law it should be
up to individuals to decide for
themselves whether that's something they
want to do abortion is an
extraordinarily safe medical procedure
in most cases it's not even a procedure
it's a it's a medication
we know all about it and it should
nobody should be forced to have an
abortion but it should be available
people should decide similarly I am fine
with people deciding oh I'm gonna uh uh
I have coven and I really don't feel
well I'm having trouble breathing I'm
going to check myself into the hospital
or I'm gonna go and get bleach
both should be legal options the
evidence is that the bleach not only
doesn't work but it could really hurt
you and so again in going with the
Medical Science
doctors shouldn't prescribe bleach
okay there's no double standard here uh
but interesting interesting perspective
we've got a great bonus show for you
today First Republic Bank has failed and
it has been taken over by JPMorgan Chase
what is this doing to the economy we
will discuss we're going to talk about
weight bias in the workforce bias
against heavy people overweight people
obese people and it is actually worse
for women than men based on the data we
have very interesting story we're also
going to delve a little bit deeper into
the search for a replacement for Tucker
Carlson all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show get instant access to
the bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com that is a freaking
Predator right there the bonus show is
not predatory it's open and available
for you if you want it simply sign up at
joinpackman.com otherwise I'll be back